one really standout moments from the  residency period was this little  second-hand shop this husband and wife  were running it and they invited me into  the back and I had no idea how far back  this was gonna go but it was kind of  meters on meters on meters all the way  back to the end of a 300 year old  warehouse and it was a trove in the back  he showed me some incredible woodblock  prints the sort of most special to me  were these sheets of washi paper with  these super old and important texts that  sometimes scholars come to study that  just are hardly ever seen and it's just  one of those moments when things all  kind of come to really profound boiling  point  [Music]  you